this program is being presented to you
by the Heras International Winter School
on Gravity and
[Music]
Light good morning welcome to the fifth
lecture of the introduction to general
relativity today we talk about tangent
spaces now under this rather unassuming
name uh goes really a lot of the basic
concept uh mathematically uh that
underly general relativity so this is a
really important lecture and there is a
lead question the lead question is the
following on a manifold if you consider
a
curve what is the velocity of that curve
at the point P now this is velocity and
not speed uh and later on we will meet
speed but speed cannot be defined before
a so-called metric is defined on a
manifold that will come later will start
with velocity and it is tradition to
call the velocity a vector and in fact
it will be a vector in our formalism but
I ask you at first to completely erase
anything you ever learned about
velocities we're trying to rediscover it
so what is the velocity of a curve gamma
at a point P and rather than making many
motivating introductory remarks that are
going to confuse you further uh we
immediately start uh with the definition
and then we discuss the definition so
first is
velocities the definition is as follows
we consider a smooth
manifold
MOA that's a topological manifold with a
smooth atlas and we consider a curve on
that manifold a curve gamma from R into
the manifold that is at least
C1 so it can be once continuously
differentiated with respect to the
charts of this smooth
atlas and um we
suppose that the curve gamma at some
parameter value lambda 0 hits this point
P because otherwise it's meaningless to
ask what the velocity of the curve at
the point P is now there's the following
definition the
velocity the velocity of gamma at P is
and now it comes the linear map so this
is something you need to get used to
that velocities in vectors in general
but we start with velocities are linear
maps is the linear map that we call
curly V like velocity of the curve gamma
in the point P the velocity of the curve
gamma in the point P what mathematical
object is it it's a linear map a linear
map needs to go from one vector space to
another vector space the vector space we
start from and which I will explain in a
second is the vector space C infinity M
or inspiring name very simple object
linear mapped into the real
numbers which are an R vector space if
you equip them with their own addition
and
multiplication now this guy what is it
this is the guy very simply of all
smooth functions on the manifold so if f
is a smooth
function then c infinity m as a set is
the collection of these smooth functions
equipped with we need addition and s
multiplication and that is just
pointwise so two of those are added
point so I declare the addition to be a
smooth map again defined at a point P of
the manifold as f of p plus g of p where
this plus is now the plus in the real
numbers where these functions take their
values and similarly lambda g of p
defined as lambda times in the real
numbers g of p and the set with these
two operations is a vector space it's
the vector space of smooth functions so
it makes sense to talk about a linear
map from here to here and the velocity
is a linear map that eats arbitrary
function any function and spits out a
real number according to the following
rule it takes this function and it maps
it to v gamma p of f now I need to tell
you how this is defined this is f after
gamma you take the derivative of that
and you evaluate at the parameter value
lambda
0 that's it that is the velocity of
gamma at a point p
now an intuition for this is very
helpful and in fact if you find this uh
surprising as a definition for velocity
this is exactly what children
uncorrupted by high school
physics capture as the concept of
velocity because it's the following you
run around through the world as a child
and you observe the world around you so
say that in the world around you there
is some temperature function f but you
must be able to do it for any f right
but if you see some temperature function
whose level lines I drew here you run
through the world and you see as you run
around as a child you look at the
temperature wherever you are so you have
the situation that you run
around which is this and there is a
temperature around and you feel the
temperature wherever you are so the temp
this is just a function from R to R time
time temperature okay and you observe
how the temperature changes the rate of
change of temperature as you run along
okay so what this is this gives you the
directional derivative of F as you run
along the curve gamma if you're at the
point P you feel how that changes so the
velocity of a curve at the point P is
the directional derivative and in the
past so this is really just in order to
make contact in the past you might have
talked uh about the velocity and now I'm
talking in charts i'm going to make this
precise i I I should only write this
like this you might have thought about
the directional derivative more like
this you take the gradient of f you dot
it into
the what you would say yes that's a
vector right you would have dotted it
into there and that's the directional
derivative now of course you can
consider this but this is only really
very roughly you could of course say no
vi del i is the differential operator
that acts on f and the only shift in
philosophy is that rather than saying
the this is the vector or the components
of the vector in differential geometry
you say this is the vector it's a linear
map that takes an f and maps it to a
number because you evaluate at a point
so you rather pull this derivative to
there right so um one could say in
programmatic gravity we want to
understand vectors or vectors in
differential geometry survive as the
directional derivatives they induce but
if you know how this acts on any
function you can make it act on the
coordinate functions and then you get
deltas and then you can recover all the
components so really if you know the
directional derivative how it acts on
just any function you can fully recover
the components okay this very sim is a
very simple shift of of now you can say
this is the basis for for these
components okay so now delete everything
I said because everything I said will
now be made precise where exactly it
takes place okay but so there is nothing
fantastic happening it's just a very
slight shift of perspective which is
extremely powerful uh and leads to the
whole idea of tangent spaces in
differential geometry okay so this is
actually a very intuitive concept we're
coming back to
that now immediately we come to tangent
spaces or the tangent vector
space because that is what's going what
is it go what it's going to be uh the
definition is as follow
definition for each
point P of the
manifold we define the
set so first of all a set t
subpm called the tangent
space 2
m at the point
p tpm and this is simply the collection
of all
possible tangent vectors to all possible
smooth curves through the point
okay so
um the picture for this
set is you have a point and you look at
all the curves through that point and
that curve will have a tangent vector
here you could say a directional
derivative associated with it uh and
this curve has one and that curve has
one well there will be a curve exactly
like the other one going through the
same point but at double parameter speed
that will give you a different
directional derivative because it scales
we'll see all this uh there could be
through a point one curve that's
different from another one but
nevertheless they give the same tangent
vector and so on it's very intuitive so
um this is almost the picture you just
have to think at the uh tangent vectors
or the velocities at this point as being
associated to this curve now do you see
we defined the tangent space as these
velocities as these maps none of this
constructions made any um reference to
an ambient space around it so although
for intuitive purposes you might think
of the TPM in a fashion I uh alluded to
last time a little like this this would
make reference to an ambient space but
this is actually the cleverer notion now
in the beginning of differential
geometry there was a debate for many
years is it better to define objects
intrinsically only lying within the
manifold or is it better to take the
manifold embedded in a bigger space and
then take this exttrinsic point of view
and does it lead to the same results and
famous embedding theorems at all
structural levels say it doesn't matter
you always find a big enough ambient
space to embed it into understand it in
this way okay so this debate is settled
now the question is why do we take this
perspective rather than this one well if
this is finally going to be the universe
all of the universe spacetime it would
be a little bit uneconomical to refer to
something around the universe right so
it's better to talk from within the
universe to define all the concepts
that's somehow a clever choice so we
prefer this and also technically it
points to the right ideas okay so um
rather this than
this rather this than this as a picture
although really everybody thinks of it
like this as well okay but technically
you must not so that's the definition of
the tangent space and um well that is
just a set now the question is do the
velocities at a
point form a vector space uh well that
is true they do so observation and it's
a key observation
um
TPM can be
made into a vector space and because
this is so important and this is a
technical key point that you're going to
use all the time I'll show this in
detail and already in this calculation
you learn all the techniques that you
need in the future for your own
calculations so it's not just a proof
that you then never look at again it's
an important construction so what do we
need to do we define an addition and an
S
multiplication and that's very
easy because the elements of here are
linear maps with values in R well so you
can immediately add them so you can
immediately take an element of TPM and
an element of the same TPM so you cannot
take a vector here and a vector here and
add them that's not possible but you can
two ve take two vectors at the same
point and you can immediately add them
so you get um v um gamma p plus v
um delta p it's the vector because all
the elements are velocities to some
curve two different elements will be
defined with respect to different
underlying curves
right you can immediately define this um
because you know this is such a linear
map you can apply it to an arbitrary
smooth function and you define the sum
as gamma p acting on f plus gamma v
delta p acting on the same f and this is
just the addition in the real numbers
whereas this defines the addition in tpm
okay you can immediately add because of
the structure of these objects and then
you have an S multiplication R cross TP
uh and that works like lambda S
multiplication V of some gamma P defined
by action on F exactly the same with the
real numbers V gamma P acting on F
now I can add them all right but there's
one problem if I add two maps what I get
out is a map map of that type and a map
of that type is a map from C infinity M
to R a real map so it's a map from C
infinity M to R i could have also
written C infinity M star and here the
same home a map from C infinite temp R
because well that's just what you get if
you add two such maps however in order
for these to be a vector space addition
and s multiplic multiplication it is
necessary that they the these two
operations close within TPM so that you
don't just get a map of this type but
you get a map of this type that lies in
C infinity M R that lies in this
specific subset it needs to be a map
that can be generated of this type that
can be generated from a
curve that is not clear you can add and
you have a map but is it generated from
this curve so it remains to be shown so
we're always almost there it remains to
be
shown that
um first there exists a curve
sigma sigma curve such that the sum
uh of the velocity of gamma at p plus
the velocity of delta at p that there
exists a curve sigma such that the sum
is not only a map of the type but is
actually the velocity ity of a third
curve at the point arises in the way in
which the elements of this space must
arise
okay it's important and similarly uh uh
it must be shown that there exists a
curve I don't know how to call it like a
sigma towel curve such that lambda * v
gamma p is v to comma p okay so this we
need to do so the remaining
proof focuses or can focus on this let's
start with this first case right we have
this V gamma P and we do the S
multiplication we defined right here
okay i need to find a curve towel such
that the result is the velocity of this
curve toao okay um I construct this
curve you can say how do you construct
this well by looking at it it's easiest
to just construct
this so um we define the curve
toao as a curve r to
m
by ascending
lambda to tow of lambda but tow of
lambda iso ah lambda is a is a bad
choice because I chose lambda here i
need to choose a different parameter
um well because I'm so used to to we are
also used to using lambda as the
parameter let's take here an alpha as
the multiplication right so alpha is the
real number by which I
multiply okay so um I set this to sigma
and I run through the old curve at alpha
times the parameter speed if you wish
okay I just do this and It's clever to
write this as sigma after mu down alpha
of lambda where the mu down alpha is a
very simple thing it takes a real number
to a real number r to alpha times this
number well this is of course what's
written here you take the mu of lambda
this is alpha* lambda that's this we
write it like this because we need to do
the chain rule in a second okay so I
just claim this curve does the
trick this curve is the one that
reproduces alpha times this well let's
calculate
um
since we look at what's the tangent
vector to the new curve towel in the
point P ah and um we also if we first
check that t at the same parameter value
lambda 0 is sigma of
alpha lambda
0 ah I should have aha it needs to go
through the same
point well it will for some lambda zero
it will hit the point but I need to
um hang on a second i need
to take So the curve sigma not sigma I'm
sorry the curve gamma went through the
point P oh now you deleted it okay uh
through the point P at parameter value
lambda 0 so I take lambda minus lambda 0
at this point why not and then t of 0
will be gamma
of gamma of lambda 0 now we got it it do
I do it like this then the t of 0 will
be gamma of lambda 0 and then I can
calculate the velocity to toao at the
point p as now by definition it's f
after
toao I take this like this and I take
the derivative at the point where we run
through p but this is here the parameter
value zero okay this is one way to do it
equals and now I need to take this
derivative and for that it's clever to
write down what I wrote down here this
this um so I take this mu alpha I have
here plus lambda 0 for simplicity is
gamma after mu alpha of
lambda okay uh this is an r this is an r
that's fine so I now have this uh chain
rule is f after gamma after mu
alpha derivative at the point zero and
now of course you know how to do this
this is f after
gamma derivative at the point mu alpha
of 0 but mu alpha of 0 is just lambda
0 times the inner derivative is the
derivative of this guy with respect to r
so this is just an alpha time alpha oh
that's excellent because this is alpha
times the velocity to gamma in the point
p because gamma of lambda 0 is the point
p
okay so sorry for the intermediate
confusion but here so there exists a
curve indeed this curve towa reproduces
this here okay so that was the easy part
uh now comes the almost as easy part um
so that's
number please leave this for a second
for one second please okay
um so now for the sum
H it works as follows well we'll leave
it for for a moment it works as follows
so we want to look at the velocity to
gamma at a point P plus the velocity to
delta at a point P and we need to
construct we need to find a curve
sigma that at the point P has the
velocity that corresponds to what I
defined here so construct in order to
construct this curve we need to do
something extremely ugly we make a
choice of
chart make a
choice of chart
ux that contains the point in question
we're looking at now the moment I say
make a choice of chart immediately your
illdefinition alarm
bells need to
ring say okay I bear with you but please
if in the end anything depends on this
chart I'm not going to buy it okay it's
very important so again I'm not against
choosing charts I'm just against
choosing charts and not knowing what a
great uh assumption ass you're making
here okay but it turns out it's no
assumption at all make a choice of chart
and
define we define the curve sigma in the
real world R to M as
follows sigma of
lambda
is I define now a curve in the chart and
once I have it I take it back into the
real world by X to the minus one okay
and in the chart I take the chart
representative of the curve
gamma and I take it at the point lambda
0 plus lambda lambda 0 is the point
where gamma hits p plus I take the chart
representative of the curve delta at the
point lambda 1 plus lambda lambda 1 is
the point where delta hits p and I
subtract a constant r d element namely x
after gamma at the point lambda zero
that doesn't depend on lambda at all
nevertheless I need it and this is in
the chart and of course in the chart
this is an element for specific lambda
this is an element in RD and uh with the
lambda free it's a map from here to here
I can add this in RD I can add this in
RD in the
chart terribly illdefined from a general
point of view if you didn't have a chart
wouldn't make any sense but you do this
in the chart and you go back from the
chart to the real world which doesn't
make it better because you need the x
and the x inverse right nevertheless
bear with me I claim this sum this sigma
does the
trick this sigma in the real world
satisfies this up here now this we need
to
calculate since so the first thing we
need to do we need to see whether sigma
at all hits this point P and at what
parameter value um we need to look at
sigma of
zero and maybe in order to uh remind
ourselves of the terrible sin we
committed we indicate the sigma subx so
we have a constant reminder this
construction depends on the chart map X
okay so what is sigma X of 0 equals X
after gamma of lambda 0 plus I write it
down is X after gamma of lambda 0 X
inverse plus X after delta of lambda 1
minus X after gamma of lambda 0 i need
this one to kill this one and then I
have just X inverse X delta this is
delta of lambda 1 is the point p okay so
the parameter z value is zero it runs
through p otherwise this makes no sense
in the first place and now the actual
calculation is as follows v of this
curve sigma x that I claim to do the
trick sigma x in the point p equals well
let's use the definition acting on a
function i need to have it act on a
function to calculate is f after this
sigma
x prime at the parameter value where it
hits p that's zero at zero that's this
thing we need to calculate and we need
to end up here if we did we found if we
do we found the
curve equals now um
aha um I plug it in or I choose another
intermediate chart I use an intermediate
chart So f after x inverse after x after
sigma
x I I'm allowed to do this right I
insert the identity that's the standard
trick derivative at zero and then I use
the associativity of the composition to
rebracket like this now this is the
derivative and now let's see what kind
of objects we have this is a function
from rd to r right maybe it helps to uh
to write down What happens here the
curve gam sigma lands here the arbitrary
function f is defined there we have a
chart here we have f after x inverse and
here we have x after sigma so we know
that f after x inverse goes from a part
of rd to r and x after sigma x so guys
sigma x sigma x after sigma x is this
one goes from R to
RD to RD and between them there's a
composition there's a derivative
fantastic is undergraduate analysis
right so we do the multi-dimensional
chain rule of undergraduate analysis and
that works as follows we take the inner
derivative first well doesn't don't you
don't need to take it first but we need
to take it so you take the derivative at
the point zero but because here this is
multialued you take the i component of
it or you can also put the i component
here and take it here it's the Same
thing and here you take the partial
derivative in the i direction okay of
the i entry here this is this f after x
inverse and after you did the derivation
you evaluate at the point x after sigma
x of 0 x of sigma x of zero sigma x of
zero is p so that's at the point x of p
okay so now we're left with the task of
calculating this beast where sigma x is
given like this let's do this first
that's not so difficult because x or
maybe I put the i here it's really the
same thing because that's the final
function that a map that acts it's the
no I put it here it's x after sigma x
that means that kills this bit
and so we have here a function from R to
RD and its E component oh we know how to
derive this we derive this and this and
this what's the result the derivative of
the first one with respect to lambda is
X after
gamma prime evaluated at aha at zero is
evaluated at lambda 0
okay um plus then this part because the
x inverse has been killed right uh that
freezes here this is x after delta prime
at lambda 0 evaluated is at lambda 1 and
this is constant this doesn't contain
lambda at all so there is nothing else
to it so this part here is this and now
you see the magic although we had this
terrible construction where we go down
to the chart add there terribly
illdefined illdefined it's well defined
here but it's illdefined under a change
of chart the derivative here at the end
of the day leads you a product a sum
rule okay and so what you get here you
now see it it's this factor here in
front is this guy and that's of course
distributive over this number which is
in R this multiplication which is in R
but what Is this well I write it down
it's um x after gamma prime at lambda 0
time del i f after x
inverse at p at x of p plus the same
expression with x after delta prime at
lambda 1 time del i f after x inverse at
x of p but now we do this backwards with
the chain rule multi-dimension i'm sorry
I took the i here so I should should
have had an i here and here so I have an
i here and an i here which is contracted
like this and now I do the
multi-dimensional undergraduate chain
rule backwards and what I get is
um uh is uh f after
um
gamma hang on a second um f
after I get f aha so I get first this
thing here and then I can remove the
others this is f after gamma prime at
zero plus f after delta prime at zero no
at lambda 0 and at lambda 1 right these
are the evaluation points here and
that's of course nothing but the
velocity to gamma at p plus the
velocity after I acted on f plus the
velocity of delta at p after acting on f
aha so we compared the left hand side
with the right hand side we didn't make
any assumption on f other than that it
comes from this set that is we have
exactly v gamma p with this addition
which is defined like this delta p is v
sigma
p and although we intermediately chose
this chart neither the left hand side
nor the right hand side depends on that
so in fact uh this is the curve that
does the trick yes i don't see where so
I didn't really get the exact point we
have to do the proof that there exists a
curve C such that the result we already
defined is a well
defined C infinity such that the result
arises as the tangent to a curve yes
and then you made use in your so I can
prove the existence by just constructing
one yes and there you pointed out uh
that it might not might not
exist such a chart no no no no i I No no
i constructed a candidate for a curve
that does the trick by using a chart by
using a chart
somewhere at this point that my
colleague pointed out there might not
even
no no the chart if if I I choose some
chart the point is no no I don't need to
assume the existence of a special chart
make a choice of any chart that covers
the point and that that is possible is
the definition of a topological manifold
it must be chart independent it must
only be chart independent so if I had
chosen another chart would the result
change the quick answer is no because
you would have a y everywhere but the
result would work out the same precisely
we couldn't because I couldn't I didn't
make any further assumptions on the
chart thank you for the question yes yes
you told us that it is better to think
in this completely intrinsic picture yes
but here we see
without seeing that we have a
manifold which can be which can be
mapped to the real space we cannot
perform this nevertheless it is
necessary that locally we can describe
whatever is by a linear ukidic
okay I wouldn't agree with the ukidian
but the idea is right the only thing I
meant is in with the picture with the
tangent space so it's the idea of a
topological manifold that locally its
point can be mapped in a continuous way
one to one uh uh to some RD but what I
meant by this embedding picture is that
you choose an R to the
1,000 to look at a fivedimensional
manifold well you don't need to go that
high but say in order to look at an a
three-dimension manifold you might have
to go to R seven to embed it such that
what you get by the intrinsic
construction which only works with R3s
that you get it as the tangent spaces as
you would define them if you were in an
R seven so so that even that's even
worse that really goes to an ambient
space that lies around it whereas the
manifold definition just requires that
pieces of the manifold can go to an R to
the dimension of the manifold okay so so
that that that's the difference but it's
exactly the point of not looking at an
arbitrary topological space then for an
arbitrary topological space you don't
have charts in the first place so we
make a huge assumption we make we say
the whole universe or whatever you look
at the whole manifold locally it looks
like RD that's a massive assumption uh
and that's the assumption that spacetime
or space is a topological manifold yes
on the first line there the x
disappeared and I must admit that I I do
not see uh if we did the chain chain
rule
forward then x would Okay so you want me
to in insert one more line uh the chain
rule of just this bit backwards the
other bit works the same the chain of
just this bit backwards is f after x
inverse after x after gamma derivative
at um the point uh lambda
zero plus and then the same thing over
here and here okay it vanishes again and
then you get this and the same here it
does vanish it goes away very
importantly yes i was confused by the
proof of the first yes can you explain
in words why we didn't use over there
oh because Yeah okay so so so okay
picture picture for the proofs okay so
the first one went like this you have
the real world m and you have a curve in
there and um I indicate equal intervals
of the parameter until I arrive at this
point by well by equal by by by by these
lengths so every time this curve is
interrupted the parameter has increased
by
one now
um very
intuitively intuitively really
intuitively you may think of the
velocity as this little arrow in fact it
turns out in the real world you must not
think of an arrow but in the chart you
can nevertheless I now do this because
but I want you to think of this arrow as
the directional derivative in the
direction of this arrow okay because we
know that is what a vector is so this is
a bad bad picture but it's not so bad to
understanding the proof so this is what
we would draw normally now the idea was
if you want to draw
double if you want to produce double
this velocity you run just run through
the curve at double parameter velocity
like this and this is what the map
mu2 did well it was a mu alpha but what
the map mu2 did and the statement was
that the tangent to this first curve is
two times the tangent to the second
curve if I compose the first curve gamma
if I compose it after mu2 before it eats
the parameter it's doubled and then you
get a curve and for that you don't need
a chart to define it i could have pushed
it down in a chart too but that wouldn't
be economical because here so the the
multiples you get by just running
through the same curve faster but the
sum is a real beast because the sum up
here so you have two curves right in the
real world you first need to go down to
a chart so where the two curves look
like this and now you use the chart to
define the sum of the curves which might
look like this that's our sigma but the
bad thing is if I pull the sigma back
this is what we did well this is the
sigma down this is x of sigma x after
sigma right if you pull the curve sigma
up you might get say this in the real
world the problem is if you had taken
the same two initial curves gamma and
delta and you had pushed them into
another chart there they may have looked
like this you would have gotten the
sigma with respect to the other chart
the sigma y you would pull this sigma y
back to the real world and you would get
a curve through the same point or right
and would be a curve that looks maybe
like this it turns out that the tangent
is independent of the choice of chart at
this point but the curves are different
so the curve the sum of curves defined
via a chart is chart dependent but it's
chart dependent in just such a way that
the tangents at the point with this
subtracted in this way and blah blah
blah so that everything fits oh that
reproduces the same tangent vector so
it's independent of the choice of chart
the sum of curves is bad but its
derivative at the point of intersection
is good but in fact we only use it at
this point yes exactly and therefore
it's fine that's that's the idea but it
shouldn't mean that you can add these
curves because otherwise you could add
the trajectories of particles
represented in a chart and that would
amount to adding position vectors which
don't exist so this is yet another point
where if you think of position vectors
and then pointing at paths and so on you
could add them the addition is
meaningless yet another proof that
position where is the problem in
thinking of the sun in the same way as
we did here
you can't because um here you can
provide this by scaling the parameter
but the curves gamma and delta they land
here and if you want to define an uh a
hypothetical uh
addition you can't simply add the maps
because on the target you you couldn't
say you do this at lambda by taking
gamma at lambda and delta at
lambda because you would have to somehow
have an operation here that you want to
put but for instance a plus doesn't
exist because you don't have that
so at least in this way you can't do it
the point is you can't do it in any way
okay
so um so that's why you can't add them
again positions do not constitute a
vector space it's always the same thing
um this is yet another another example
of that all right good are there
questions so far
yes one more question about the first
sigma x you chose here yes so the smart
move is to choose it in a way that we
have different arguments lambda zero and
lambda and lambda one and so on that at
the end of the day we have again our two
derivatives with the two different
arguments which are not dependent on
lambda yes to say okay yes but since we
have x inverse applied to the whole
thing on the right hand side aren't we
charting dependent from the start no
because in this for in this definition
you can't take out the x you can take
out the x here x inverse after x is the
identity but x if the definition only
went up to this point of course you
could write gamma of lambda 0 plus
lambda but then you add in the chart and
this is not a linear map right and so
you cannot pull it
apart you can't okay that's the point
context sensitive plus that's the point
right a context yeah well it's it's a
plus on this RD I know you would have
just cut it oh yeah that then then it
would go out in the beginning in in but
then you wouldn't have p uh constructed
a sum
yet right that's right okay
good perfect excellent in
time okay please the blackboard yes
view yes repeat the question to repeat
the question yes thank you thank you so
here the question was um whether the x
doesn't go out already in the definition
the answer is no because the x inverse
is not a linear map thank you all
Yes you need to check all the other all
the actions for the vector space uh yes
in principle you do but it's always the
same construction of course you do and
you can do yourself but it's always the
same construction because we added maps
that whose target is R we inherit the
addition from R over there and almost
everything immediately comes from the
axums of the field R
um so that's K plus K times for R
without zero and the distributive law
and with them you inherit all the vector
space aums in a few steps so it's it's a
standard standard con construction but
you're right I have to to show that in
principle okay but so anything I do not
show you have my uh quality guarantee
it's
true okay so we have a notion of
velocities we have maybe this intuition
oh they survive as directional
derivatives and because I know how they
act on anything they could act on the
coordinate functions that would give
deltas and I could extract the
components again so so maybe you're
happy with this um but the point is it's
very useful to now go to a chart to take
the abstract notion of velocity which
will later on in physics correspond to
the velocity of a particle in the real
world so that's the physical the im our
picture mathematical object representing
the physical velocity of a thing fully
independent of any coordinate choice
okay fully independent of coordinate
choice and fully independent of a choice
of length so in order to con to to to
provoke uh contradiction but I I won't
defend it at the moment i will defend it
later the physical dimension of speed is
meters/s say okay we all agree and
that's right what is the physical
dimension of the components of a
velocity vector say well it's also
meters per second it isn't it's hertz
it's one over
second okay so this is just to provoke
you um you will learn and you'll in the
end say "Oh dear it's really true." But
that we'll only do after the lecture
next Wednesday and then you'll realize
where the missing meter is coming from
okay but it's an important point it's
important point and it also stalled
Einstein for many years not having
understood this first
okay so now let's do what you're all
longing for you want to reconcile this
abstract notion of velocity in the real
world with components so
components of a
vector with respect to a
chart and we learn much more than about
the components because if you have
components of a vector you need to know
about the basis so what is the basis of
the tangent spaces or of a tangent space
because in this lecture we pick a point
P and we'll stay
solidly within one tangent space and
only the lecture after this one will
then look at all the tangent spaces
together and consider vector fields and
so on so anyway components of a vector
with respect to a chart
definition let
ux be a chart in the smooth manifold of
the smooth underlying manifold we have
here and let gamma be a curve from r
well from r into u into m but it should
hit
uh if this is the u uh the curve should
hit the point p and it better lie in the
chart we're looking at okay let be gamma
thus be the portion of a curve that lies
in U and then we can and let's also
assume gamma of zero for simplicity hits
the point P can all assume all of that
now we
calculate we calculate we start with
just the
vector tangent to the velocity of the
curve gamma in the point P we just start
with that what is that well in order to
really understand it we need to let it
act on an arbitrary
function it is f after gamma derivative
at the point zero that's what it is
directional derivative now we insert our
chart just for fun in order to get it
into the game we have this at zero we
rebracket like this you see it's always
the same calculation that's why one can
do them and here you have from RD to R a
map and here you have a map from R to RD
or always portions of RD now we do the
chain rule as before but now let's look
at another aspect i take X after gamma
the I component then I take the
derivative at position zero that's the
inner derivative now I take the outer
derivative that's the derivative with
respect to the i direction there's the
summation of f after x inverse and
that's evaluated at x of gamma of zero
that's evaluated at x of
p now this expression and this
expression will appear again and again
and again and remember this is a
function here is a function from RD to R
and in the tutorials learned that the
partial derivative we will not write d
by dx or something like this because all
you need to know to take the partial
derivative is you need to know with
respect to which entry do you derive it
has nothing to do with how you will
after you derived name the
entries it's enough it's it's the um
equivalent of in
uh analysis you have a function from R
to R so this is analysis undergraded
analysis the derivative of F is denoted
FP prime and it's again a function and
you may evaluate frime of X or you may
evaluate frime of Y that doesn't make a
difference the derivative is called FP
prime it would be very silly to say oh
only because I give a certain
prescription like this therefore I
should write the derivative as df by dx
because the abstract notion of
derivative has nothing to do whether I
defined this by x or defined this by
alpha right so this bad notation we're
not going to use we say with respect to
the
derivative now however here in this
expression and now you okay I need many
colors now in this expression uh let's
first take the expression over here so
after the multiplication sign this
expression here has many elements in it
and it's very cumbersome to
write and we write it
differently we write it dell because
there's a dell in
it we write by dell well there's still a
dell in it this x here now you need to
be very observant there's an X here and
there's an X here and in order to
remember that it's an X and not a Y we
put a X
here now there is an I down
here this I has nothing to do with the X
nothing nevertheless we put it up here x
I okay this is just notation that's the
point and there is an F here that's the
blue F great it's the blue F we put the
blue F here we still haven't taken care
of the P well we put brackets around it
and we put the little P running out of
colors uh we're putting the little P
down
here that's our notation for this and
you say "Oh partial
derivative." No no because of course
it's designed to make you look to look
like this because later on you can prove
that this object satisfies all the rules
you would like this guy to have if you
don't know anything about the background
right so this makes the R accessible to
the masses uh but but
the but but the point is it's very
important to to realize this point the
function
f here is a function from m to the real
numbers or rather from u to the real
numbers because we're depending on this
chart um so whenever you see this symbol
don't be deceived by its simplicity you
immediately need to translate it into
this no alternative to that okay now
here we do something similar uh but this
is just for fun to make it look even
more normal um this is the chart
representative of the curve gamma with
respect to x and the i component of it
which after I took the i component I
derive and I evaluate at the point zero
and because we already used here some
funny notation I take the freedom to put
it here as a dot with respect to the
parameter it's just for fun uh so I can
define this here as well okay so what do
We have we have that the velocity to a
curve gamma in the point P as it acts on
F equals the chart representative of the
curve with respect to the chart X that I
chose the I component of it so this is
what the undergraduate idea of a
position of a curve is and you take the
derivative at the point you're
interested in a parameter value zero
because you're interested in the point P
times the well you may be tempted to say
this is the directional derivative
operator and you let the whole thing act
on the f and that's what I wrote down
very much in the beginning you have a
notion of components of vector you dot
them into partial derivatives and that
acts on the function only that the
function we are dealing with is not a
function on the chart the function here
is a smooth function
on the
manifold okay so however we have this uh
we and it's tradition to delete these
brackets to say a vector acts on
whatever is behind it it's tradition uh
because then it's even simpler to look
at just this bit of the equation and
this
bit because this is true for all f in C
infinity m so as
maps as a map which is which this object
is it's equal to if you use a chart
under use of chart you can understand
the vector as what you would normally
say are its components and how you
calculate this you derive the components
but because it's a vector it doesn't
only have components it also has a
basis and obviously Quite obviously if
these are called the components of the
vector which we will say these are the
components of the
velocity V gamma P then this guy here
these must be the basis
elements basis elements of well of the
space in which this guy lives where does
it live it live in the tang lives in the
tangent space these must be the basis
elements of the
TPM with respect to
which the
components need to be
understood right if I talk about
components of a vector I need a basis
for the vector now here what we have is
the so-called chart
induced
basis
of
TPM choice of a chart
X gives you a choice of bases in the
tangent space but of course it's fully
irrelevant what chart you choose you
could have chosen a different chart
would give you a different basis in the
tangent space okay so um now for
pictures in the real
world which might just look like this
you may have a vector here that looks
like this you may in another tangent
space have a vector like this another
like this and another like this and so
on okay a feel like that
um it's good I didn't do it rotating to
the right maybe uh well so the point is
you can map this down to a chart well
first of all what you map to the chart
to the
R2 is the points you know you have a a U
here and each point goes to a point here
via a chart map X
right but now imagine that the way I do
this is that if I pull this coordinate
net backwards by X
inverse I would get
this okay this is now going bad okay I
need to first draw the the net and
then I could have chosen polar
coordinates which means this net is
mapped to this apart from some slits and
so on and uh you have your your vectors
here attached like
this now what you can do you can of
course the circle up here the points
These points here are of course simply
this in a polar coordinate system right
if you think of this x2 as the phi and
of this x1 as the r it's the generalized
coordinates of classical mechanics it
looks like this so what do you guess are
the components of these vectors at the
various points well there will be
something like
this drawn into if you now take the idea
okay you have these components one uh uh
0 1 0 1 0 1 all the time and then you
draw them at the respective base point
this one here and this one here and so
on and then you see yes your vectors are
associated with components but in the
chart it can look dramatically different
from the world if you wish and depends
on the chart clearly if you now make a
so-called cartisian coordinate system of
the same situation in the real world so
this is a bird flying in a circle that's
an objective reality but in a polar
coordinate chart it runs like this would
you say it runs along a straight line in
reality no it doesn't right but in this
chart it looks like that so you see the
components of vectors heavily depend on
the chart and in principle drawing them
up here is a bad idea you should only
always draw them down
here okay but nevertheless there is a
velocity that the bird has here and
there's a velocity but in this chart it
looks like this okay so uh that is this
um number
four is uh the chart induced
basis and I already mentioned it so you
have the
definition if
ux is a chart in the smooth atlas
uh
then d by
dx1 at the point p dot dot dot dot d to
dxd at the point p these are all
elements of tpm because they're the
corresponding maps right and they
constitute a
basis of
TPM okay so we already saw they generate
TPM because I can represent every vector
in that basis uh it remains to show
proof so it's not a definition it's a
theorem well of the easy type uh prove
it remains to be shown that they're
linearly
independent how do we do this well we
need to take the
vectors and I may call them vectors
because they lie in the tangent vector
space we take these guys and we multiply
them with lambdas and take the sum and
require this be zero and we need to be
able to show that therefore all the
lambdas are zero that's linear
independence but that's simple because I
simply apply the whole
thing to the J coordinate
function and in the tutorials you
learned that the J coordinate function
okay I'm sorry I said constitutes a
basis of TPM it only constitutes a basis
of the TPS that attached to the chart
domain right only in this area
um and uh we learned in the tutorials
that the chart maps that go from the
coordinate maps that go from U to R that
they're differentiable with respect to
the maps in this atlas to the charts in
this atlas right so we are allowed to
apply it here because it's a function
from U to R and now comes we would say
oh dxj by dxi that must be a delta j
well I told you whenever you see the
symbol you need to reconstruct what it
really means so let's do that so let's
do it up here it's better can see this
better so this means Yep i did not get
why TPM and TPU are different
tpu is just an area so you have the uh
the whole world you have the domain U in
the domain u
uh your chart is
valid and um all we use the chart map
and so you can only uh intuitively
speaking this is the basis you have in
the real world but I shouldn't draw it
as arrows but this only works in the
domain u and generally we'll come to
that you can next lecture you cannot ex
you cannot generally for any manifold
you cannot for every manifold
find a global chart in the first place
but even if you can cover it by global
charts you might not be able to find a
global coordinate induced um uh a basis
of the basis field
you're doing you're varying the P within
the No no no no i I said so the
statement is for any point in P okay for
any point in U
right so so this is always the
assumption that the chart contains the
point P i I should always emphasize this
so the point P must always lie in the
chart or rather the chart must be a
neighborhood for the point okay so I
apply this here so what is the
definition of this symbol it means take
the dell i compare i think it's still
down there take the the i and put it
down in the dell then take the function
you're acting on that's XJ do it after X
inverse after X inverse and evaluate at
X of the point P that's down here i just
did this blindly this is just
this by
definition
okay right but now you see ah that's
very simple this is XJ after X inverse
what does that do that goes from RD to R
and takes the
pupil alpha 1 to alpha D which is an
element of R it takes it to the alpha J
to the J
component right but doing that and
deriving it with respect to the I
component gives a one if I equals
J and so there's the sum here and this
is the delta symbol I introduced and
this is lambda J ah
um but we start with the assumption that
this object is already zero so applying
this to this yields you that all the
j are zero that means these guys are
really linearly independent
so indeed uh this constitutes a
basis and the corollary of
that is that the dimension of
TPM is of course D because you have D
basis
vectors but D ultimately came from the
fact that you have D coordinate maps so
the dimension the vector space dimension
is d and the manifold dimension which is
a very different concept is also d so
the vector the tangent space at each
point has the dimension of the manifold
well that's quite intuitive but one is a
vector space dimension and the other one
is a topological manifold dimension
yes but shouldn't it be TPU all over the
place in the right box uh well
uh this is right but it remains right if
I do this okay but you're right
constitute a basis of um of TPU is
certainly right tpm would be wrong
because not for every point p and m okay
um that's it yeah
um yes but here you I would argue I did
this now for one point but there I have
a neighborhood I can do it for another
point because it covers I know
everywhere thank you that completes the
proof
yes
okay so um time is almost up five more
minutes i ask to bear with me for maybe
15 minutes and then I don't need to rush
through it is that all right and then
maybe we we shift again because then we
get this important topic covered yes
okay
so next topic is change of vector
components under a change of chart
now in the older literature on
differential geometry statements of the
following type are to be found tensors
transform under a change of coordinate
systems as follows a vector transforms
as follows well most precisely it must
say vector components transform as
follows because the vector is an
abstract object it's the velocity of the
bird at that point of time no change in
your thinking about the coordinate
system will change the velocity the
velocity is the velocity in the real
world but if you think of the components
of the velocity in a particular chart
and you change to another chart for the
same velocity of course the components
will change there's something different
so therefore it is to be said change of
vector
components under a change of chart not
change of vector so I
emphasize
vector or tangent vector does not change
under change of
chart simply because it's defined
independently of chart how would it
change under a change of chart so uh
let's see how that works
let aha um I should have maybe added uh
some terminology here i'm sorry
terminology if X is an element of
TPM then you know two things the first
thing you know is that there always
exists a curve gamma such that so gamma
curve such that X is the velocity of
some curve to that point through that
point P if X lies in TPM so I pick an
arbitrary element of X from TPM and I
will in the future not always make
explicit the curve it comes from in fact
it doesn't come from the curve
because these two curves give the same
vector right um so therefore we'll talk
about this abstractly and um that's the
first thing we sometimes need and it
always arises like that by definition of
TPM and the second thing you know is
because it's a vector space you can
always find so they
exist x1 to x d which are all numbers in
the real real numbers such that x can be
written as a linear combination x
I D by D X I P if you have a chart but
you can also quite independently of
chart induced coordinates you could
choose because it's a vector space just
any basis in it wouldn't then come from
a chart but it would nevertheless be a
basis and you expand in components and
the X I are called the components of
this with respect to the chosen basis
and the basis may come or you may induce
it from a chart or use it at a point you
define just like this because you say I
like these three vectors to be the basis
you can do this okay you don't need to
come from a chart but if you have chosen
a chart
anyway why not because you already
committed the sin right so then you
better enjoy
it
good so change of vector components so
now in order to consider the change of
chart let's do this following let
um um u
x and y v y be charts but let them be
overlapping
charts and take a point p from their
intersection okay
now um
let x be an element in the tangent space
of this if this
intersection then we know that we can
write with respect to the chart
ux using that we can write this as x i
components d by
dxi p because that's the basis is and in
order to indicate that these are the
components with respect to the basis
from this chart we mark the components
by a little x down here but now of
course fully independently you can
choose the chart VY because the point P
is in both is in the overlap region and
you can choose different or you must
generically use
different
components with respect to the different
bases all right and the question is how
are these components related to those
components and you know there is a
relation because the abstract object in
the middle is invariant under this um
and and now we we look how this goes um
well let's simply start with this object
so in order to study
uh change of
components change of components formula
or to derive it um consider the
following we take d by
dxi at the point p and we try to
reformulate it as this
guy we know it's a map so we best
understand it if we apply it to what it
acts on namely a function and what now
well you see this symbol you know it
looks very deceptively simple but you
have to translate it you let the i jump
here you take the f here you take after
the x that's here as the full map
inverse and you evaluate at the point x
of p you need to be able to do this back
and forth in your
sleep that's what the wicket is good for
so you you have this and now of course
we want to consider a change of chart so
if you want to relate this x to this y
we better have it somewhere so we insert
it as an identity at this
point right nothing happened right we
just inserted the identity we use the
associativity of the composition and we
rebracket now things are simpler again
because this is from RD to R some
portion of RD to R and this is from RD
to RD and by the way it's an old
acquaintance is a chart transition map
however it comes here
derived so we execute the
multi-dimensional chain rule the inner
derivative is del i acting on y after x
inverse but this lands in RD so it has a
j component and it's evaluated at x of p
times now comes the outer derivative
it's this guy which is derived according
to the multi-dimensional chain rule like
this and summed over these results of f
after y inverse and after you calculate
this you evaluate at this at y after x
inverse of x of p is y of p you evaluate
at y of p okay and now you stare at this
for a little moment and you say "Oh
that's nice because
um the i derivative of the j component
of this this j comes because the y lands
in RD so you could have also taken the
coordinate function instead of the full
coordinate the full chart map and then
the J component is of course the J comp
coordinate function so but this is a
coordinate function so you have del I of
a function after X inverse X of P oh we
know this guy this is del Y is it a J
it's a J component with respect to the
DXI down P for this object we can also
use our
symbol and now you look at this you say
"Oh F after Y inverse J D." Ah this is
also our symbol this is DF but now with
a Y instead of an
X J so this is a J and this is an I at
the point P because that's what the
symbol is ah and where is this guy here
well that's a real number
and so you have here a
sum that goes like this over that and
um so here you had this symbol here you
have the f you can consider the hole as
an operator that acts on this okay and
so what did we find we found that this
guy
here because this is true for all f
didn't make any assumptions on the f is
the
same as this
guy
here
okay so uh let's insert this into
here therefore insertion into that
yields you
um how do we do that
okay uh x x x i component and for future
use let's make this a j component from
the beginning i just renamed the summing
index x i with respect to x of the d by
dxi but the d by dxi I reformulated like
this dy J by
DXI at the point P times D by
DY J at the point P equals and then I
just copy the left hand side is
XJ with respect to the Y system D by D
YJ at the point P aha but because these
are a basis I can be diff um take this
to the other side i factor out the basis
i have numbers times the basis is zero i
know the numbers are zero or
uh written like this is the J component
in the Y system is
the constructed from the I component in
the X system by multiplying with YJ by
DXi at the point P and the construct
contractions over this and this is
called this is the formula you find in
books
it says if the x i are the components of
the vector in the x indices in the basis
with respect to the x chart then the
very same vector the same abstract
object the same physical vector if you
wish as
physicists has in the y chart components
that you get by calculating these
numbers at the point
P now your change of coordinates can be
wildly nonlinear on your manifold wildly
nonlinear but now you go to one point
and you look at the components of a
vector with respect to the original
chart and because you evaluate this
widely nonlinear dependence of y and x
and stuff like this uh you evaluate this
at this one point you just get a scheme
of numbers one might say a matrix which
you one might say matrix multiply into
this column vector right but we don't
want to use the terminology you you cons
you construct the sum this is at a point
for a given change of chart from one
chart to the other chart at that point
it uses a constant matrix which is the
matrix that takes the components of the
vector in one system to the components
of them in another system so we have a
vector space and it's acted on at each
point by linear by a linear map by a
constant linear map which only acts
depends on the change of of uh of chart
although the global chart transformation
is wildly
nonlinear now what you do in special
relativity let me tell you you talk
about Minkovski vector space so doesn't
that fly in the face of everything I
said because Minkovski vector space as
the points in spacetime is a vector
space right the x mus and stuff like
this yes it flies in the face of
everything and you shouldn't say that
minkovski space the position the
space-time points in special relativity
everything is flat is not a vector space
either now you say well but the formulas
work yes they work because you
artificially restrict self to changing
from one coordinate system to another
one by linear transformations which you
further restrict to be Laurens
transformations and this sounds like a
good idea well it's a good idea for the
individual velocity vectors velocities
transform under Laurens transformations
in each point of the flat tangent space
by a linear
map now but that doesn't mean that I mix
the points on the space only by linear
maps I want to be able to do special
relativity in polar coordinates if I
wish so you can still do it you can
change from cartisian coordinates to
polar coordinates and in the velocity
tangent spaces it will induce indeed
linear maps and if you say observer
velocities should stay observer
velocities you can think about what you
have to
require but not in position space it's
an over
structuralization to equip the position
space of special relativity with a
vector space structure because you then
transform also position vectors with
Lawrence transformations which is why do
you restrict yourself like this in the
tangent spaces it makes a lot of sense
okay so that's the that's the statement
here okay so um we have this so there is
one more thing I would like to mention
and that's um co-angent
spaces and now it pays off what we did
yesterday so at a point you have a
tangent space TPM but this tangent space
is just a vector space with the
operations we defined so of course it's
quite trivial to consider the tangent
space which is a vector space and to
consider its dual so you consider all
the linear maps from TPM into the real
numbers so we're still at this point but
now we look at the dual space so very
simple and straightforward construction
now the point is simple and
straightforward but are there any
objects we're interested in that lie in
it yes there are imagine you have on
your manifold a smooth function say a
temperature
distribution then you can define the
following object D
um DF at a point P so we take a point P
uh and you define this uh as the map
that takes a tangent vector at P and
maps it linearly to the real numbers by
virtue of sending the vector to DF at
the point P of the vector and this is
defined as simply the action of the
tangent vector at that point to the
function
so you say okay this we knew how to
write down before this this directional
derivative why on earth do you want to
introduce this complicated notation well
we wrote this action x on f this way as
a map from the x space the space where
the x's are linear map to r that means
that this df at p is an element of the
co-angent space
and what is this well this is the
gradient of f so df subp is called the
gradient of f at the point p and you do
not need any charts to define the
gradient
now we can calculate the components of
the
gradient and you remember how you get
the components of a tensor it's a it's a
01 tensor right it's a 01 tensor over
TPM right in our terminology from last
time 01 tensor over the underlying
vector space which happens to be TPM in
this
construction so the gradient is a 01
tensor or a co- vector and calculate the
components how do you get the components
of a 01 tensor well you write down the
tensor
abstractly and if it's a 01 tensor it
has one index down
how are the components defined well you
take the abstract tensor and you plug in
the
basis with respect to which you wish to
get the components well a 01 tensor eats
one copy of the vector space an element
of a copy of the vector space and say we
want to do this components of the
gradient with respect to the chart
induced
basis for the chart ux why not so we
plug this in so what is this this is the
J basis vector and that was this
object let's calculate this well this
applied to this vector is actually the
vector applied to the f d by d
xj of the fp ah there we got it now it
looks deceptively like what you would do
you say you take the partial derivative
in the j direction you know that you
need to translate the symbol into del J
f after x inverse and evaluate at the
point x of p and this you can calculate
by undergraduate analysis and because
you evaluate at the point you get a
number for each j these are the
components of the gradient and the
gradient components are co-
vectors the gradient of a field of a
function is not a vector the gradient of
a function is a co- vector there's
nothing to be done about it it's a co-
vector it for instance under a change of
chart these components transform
differently than the components that
have an index up so the final thing I
write down is
the change of components i won't prove
it because you believe it works exactly
like for the vectors change of
components of a co-
vector under a change of
chart and again the same applies it's a
change of components the co- vector
remains the co- vector maybe I emphasize
this so if this is an element of TP M
star
um And you see the star is here and it's
tradition to write it there so don't be
confused it means nothing different so
if this omega is in TPM star it can be
written ah I forgot something important
i'm sorry i'm
sorry uh let me put this here
um
theorem theorem I want to give you a
coordinate a chart induced basis for the
cotangent space theorem
uh
consider a chart
ux that means you have chart maps x i
from the chart domain to the real
numbers right you have these ch
coordinate maps the claim
is well first of All they're all smooth
functions with respect to the chart
that's under the atas that's underlying
the claim is that if you take the first
such function you of course
can calculate the d of the function so
you take the function and then you apply
the d and you evaluate at p according to
this
definition and then you take the next
coordinate function this is the function
then you apply the D you evaluate at the
point P and so on up to the D coordinate
function we evaluate at the point P and
the claim is this is a basis of TP star
M and in fact it's the dual basis
in
fact this is the dual basis
uh of the dual space what do we mean by
the dual base in the dual space in the
dual space we could choose a to a basis
that's totally independent of uh this
basis we chose in the tangent space but
it turns out if we construct it as the
gradients of the coordinate
maps you can calculate you take the
gradient of the A coordinate map at the
point P and you apply it to the
B basis element of the tangent space and
you calc one second and you calculate
this you get dxa by
DXB P and by writing it in undergraduate
analysis notions you get indeed delta AB
so in fact this is not just a basis of
the dual space it's the dual basis of
the dual
space if in the original space you chose
the chart
induced basis somebody had a
question okay sorry I wanted to say this
first so we have a chart in use spaces
there too and it's given as the gradient
of the coordinate
maps now how do the components of a co-
vector which is an abstract object with
physical reality we would say as a
physicist you can expand in terms of the
dxis at a point p if this is an element
in the cotangent space and we label the
components like this of course it's a
co- vector and with respect to the x
chart and here with respect to the y
chart or y chart uh we may label them
like this and expand in the y dual basis
now you go through the same motions as
we did before for the vector you express
this in terms of the other you use again
the multi-dimensional chain rule and
what you arrive at is the fact that in
the y system the i component is given as
the i component in the x system
d and now we need to see where the y and
the x is and the rule to remember is
this index is down but I need an x and a
y they have both an index up so this
index down comes from an index up if the
object is under the line so the i must
come from here no yes the i must come
from here and this j must relate to this
one because up down right um and then
the j is an xj has an x with a j with
respect to an x i mean this is a
pneummonic rule right uh and here you
have a y so you need to find some way to
remember where which object goes and if
you compare this to the transformation
of vector components you will see this
is the matrix with x up and y down
whereas the vector components go with y
up and x down
okay if the result is the y result and
then you can show and that will be on
the problem sheet today that these two
matrices are inverses of each other so
really the components of a co- vector
under a change of chart are transformed
the other way linearly than the
components of a vector under the same
change of chart and now imagine what
happens if you call the gradient the
gradient vector and you believe your
terminology you're in direct
contradiction to the chain rule right
you don't need to know anything about
differential geometry you write down the
gradient like this you define the comp
components like this you do the chain
rule which is undergrad analysis and you
will find the wrong transformation
behavior or at least wrong compared to
the assumption that it transforms like a
vector right it's not deep it's not a
special new mathematics that makes the
gradient a co- vector it's the chain
rule of standard analysis that makes the
gradient a co- vector and not a vector
it's a very important point to keep in
mind in the tutorials in the first half
of tutorials this afternoon this has
been uh further investigated
questions okay then uh we reconvene I
suggest at 10 past thank you